Chairperson: Good morning, everyone. This public hearing of the Committee on Finance, Budget and Appropriations of the Sangguniang Bayan ng Capas is now called to order.
Committee Secretary: Chairperson, we have a quorum. Four of the five committee members are present.
Chairperson: Thank you. Before us is Proposed Ordinance No. 2026-P-018, revising the rental rates of stalls at the Capas Public Market.
Chairperson: Present today are the Municipal Treasurer, the Public Market Administrator, and representatives of our stall holders. Administrator, you have the floor.
Market Administrator: Thank you, Chairperson. Magandang umaga po sa ating lahat. After the market redevelopment, the stalls now have new roofing, better lighting, and proper drainage. Ang current rates po natin ay hindi pa nagbabago sa loob ng labing-isang taon.
Market Administrator: Under the proposal, wet market stalls will go from ₱900 to ₱1,100 a month, and dry goods stalls from ₱700 to ₱850.
Chairperson: Thank you. Let's hear from our stall holders.
Stall Holders' Representative: Magandang umaga po, Chairperson. Suportado po namin ang mga pagbabago sa palengke. Pero marami pa pong vendor ang bumabangon pa lang. Hiling po namin na unti-unti ang pagtaas, sa loob ng dalawang taon.
Chairperson: Treasurer, is a phased increase feasible?
Municipal Treasurer: Yes, Chairperson. If we apply half of the increase next year and the rest the year after, maintenance costs will still be covered. We also recommend a discount for tenants who pay on time.
Chairperson: Very well. The committee adopts the phased schedule and the prompt payment discount. The Secretariat will revise the draft accordingly.
Committee Secretary: Noted, Chairperson. The revised draft and the committee report will be ready for the 38th Regular Session.
Chairperson: Thank you, everyone. This hearing is adjourned.